let's go back to GameSpot's continuing
coverage of e3 2014 but I love about
this war mark is that we're going to
talk about airmech arena but this is
perhaps the last demo that world soccer
fans well fans will be watching because
i believe the world cup is kicking off
in about 15 minutes time i'm delighted
to have you here sir wait to be here
macrina eric of course a game that spin
its it's seen its it's been on PC
already in some sort of form at the
arena game coming out on xbox 360 free
to play for folks who aren't familiar
with the franchise ki just give a sort
of an overview as to what Irene is
particularly definitely so i'm working
at ubisoft with the dev team at carbon
games there they've been devoted and
they're super passionate about their
game airmech that they've been working
on they got it out on pc and we saw how
awesome and hardcore about community
they were building there so we recognize
that and decided hey let's bring that to
xbox 360 it should be coming out this
summer and it's going to be free to play
so we think it's going to really engage
a lot of players on xbox 360 so to get
into multiplayer matches and so we're
look we're out we're looking at the
gameplay right here yeah and so can you
just give us a sort of a breakdown of
the moment-to-moment action right we're
looking at this one of the one of nine
different air mix that we have in the
game each of the nine different air max
had different abilities right there we
see he's going through some of the
upgrades the game itself is a kind of a
combination of a MOBA with some RTS
aspects and even some twin-stick shooter
type of action so it really combines all
of this into an awesome kind of a online
multiplayer experience haha think we're
having some I don't know I don't know we
got a bit of that abe's exoddus up there
for a second for some reason I think we
can come back to us walk while those
dudes I try and set that up but yes sir
you are essentially you were controlling
one unit but you're also controlling a
battlefield so you're controlling your
airmech and with your airmech you can
build up units kind of like in an RTS
game and then give those units commands
either to attack an outpost to patrol an
area link up with other units send up
you can build up a whole way
and then send up a hole up in your enemy
base now your enemies like Oh wave of
tanks and I'm at me what am I going to
do build some turrets go with some
infantry other different types of units
there's over 60 different types of units
in the game to choose from but as you go
into each match you only have eight
slots for two picked four units so you
really have to be strategic with all
right do I need some healing units do I
need some generators to add additional
money to my match as I'm taking over
outposts so it's interesting it's it's
like a combination of a bunch of
different systems but i mean i don't
think i've ever seen them sort of laid
out in this fashion it's almost like
it's almost like you're playing a mobile
where you're able to control the creep
or you're playing a real time strategy
game but your cursor is a unit it's like
it moving around the map is actually if
it's a little bit all of that and and
your air make itself is a powerful you
know as you upgrade it the different
Eric's have different abilities if you
want to go stealth you're going to have
a stealth irmak you can have a heavy
machine gun aromatic it's warthog and
and just suit your own play style but
they can go in and they can do a lot of
damage themselves and so you can really
push hard if you're playing with other
teammates because we support up to three
be three online multi-player oh cool so
you kind of coordinate with your
teammates maybe i'll pick you know that
the warthog with a heavy machine gun and
go in and start blasting while my
teammate is you know building up waves
of units to attack and take over
outposts and take out their base
excellent so what type of game modes are
that and I'm assuming this one we've won
33 what what are 102 b 23 B 3 and online
ranks multiplayer matches we also have a
survival mode where you are just
defending a base you can play co-op in
that mode against AI and that's against
the AI ya where the waves of units are
just coming at you you have to defend as
long as possible and we have co-op modes
where you're just playing against AI as
well so you can practice your strategy
and with your teammates and friends to
figure out what works best for you cool
if anyone has any questions from marc by
all means please tweet at Daniel Dwyer
or stick it in the game spot at Josh
athan you are there and I'll do my best
to relay those to our good friend mark
here and so free to play you guys are
coming in on xbox 360 obviously a lot of
games here in the show for coming out
that new xbox thing yes they're all
talking about and what's it like bring
your game is free to play on a console
that's been ad for seven years obviously
in one way it's not getting a lot of
media focus but I'm on in another way
you've got a hella bunch of people who
own that console totally there's a huge
player base there on xbox 360 and and as
soon as they see a game come up free
whether it be through the the free to
play with coal program or just you know
a general free game they jump on it so
you know that's that's a thing we're
gonna we anticipate we'll have a lot of
players coming in checking out the game
and that's what we want to support the
online multiplayer but you know the
challenge is keeping them there and
that's the great thing with the carbon
game sir we're at support in the game
and keeping that fun aspect of new items
every once in a while they'll do holiday
items around Halloween they have a
Frankenstein as a pilot that goodbye
it's like for a limited amount of times
you gotta get in there and save up
enough to get him I know cut carbon a
lot of the guys from carpenter X Titan
developers who are the guys bind at fat
princess hey and that was a game that I
think it was a bit of a drop off in
terms community but they always tried to
provide and stuff for them to do and I
was also a game that took competitive
multiplayer and shook it off in ways
that you were kind of not really
expecting exactly and I think they're
doing again now with airmech arena it's
it's an awesome combination of different
types of gameplay it's it's it's
visceral and it really gets you to to
enjoy some intense moments moment action
it's really influenced also by an old
sega genesis game i don't know if you
remember herzog zwei no I don't that one
is it's it's really gonna made it to
Europe that's what that's my cat
sometimes I see my god will never made
it to Europe I probably did but on they
took that game and really updated it to
kind of speed up the actions feet up the
mechanics and and still keep the
strategic elements so it's really a
fast-paced game we think players are
going to you can see here from from the
sunday action
now it's a 3v3 battle and even if you
know this is a I with one of the players
being a person but but still like it's
just fast paced and and you got to be
pretty quick witted to to keep up and
get in and win let's talk about the
units and factions and stuff like that
so is it one base faction that all teams
are playing as it's just different you
can approach it differently with tech
trees and stuff so there's let me start
with the maps actually because there's
there's ten different maps unlike you
know traditional MOBAs where you have 10
just one really this one there's
different layouts for each map no
Katherine obstacles and challenges on
each map so each team starts off with
their one base on each side and from
there they can upgrade their air Mac
down specific paths so there are
secondary abilities unique to each of
the the air max there's a flying saucer
airmech it's just called saucer that guy
can has a death ray so you have to
upgrade during the match to get that
activated death ray what made you give
up you see on the red team right now
there's a saucer a guy in there we also
a paladin he has Bluffs that go out to
the his team's units also appears to be
a helicopter helicopter very good yep he
ended that one of the abilities on the
helicopter the chopper is is to be able
to carry more units as you build them
obviously the tanks are going to be a
lot heavier and harder to force the air
mix to carry so so yeah the different
air max have different abilities and
having the air max are there again nine
total air makeup so there's lots of
going back to your question about you
know the free-to-play and opportunities
to buy we definitely have you know a
starter pack and other things where
players can can buy stuff to to kind of
get a jump ahead yeah but most all of
the stuff that you would buy with real
money would be kind of a customization
bay so it's not really you know in any
way pay to win it's entirely focused on
spending the time to you know earn the
units or get the units and then learn
the best strategy that's where we really
want players to focus on is
spending time in the game learning
what's best for their their type of
gameplay and then building up their
armies to win presumably to foster any
sort of community around the game
especially competitive game you wouldn't
get away with doing any sort of pay2win
self anymore right I think I think
everybody knows nowadays you know they
can spot it when if you're throwing that
out there and so we've definitely made
it very clear that you know you can earn
enough in-game currency a through we
playing the game to be able to buy all
the units and and be competitive at the
high end level so the currency in the
actual levels themselves and I'm seeing
a lot of cool dance stuff happening for
for your build orders which is a sort of
a staple of any real time strategy game
right I want what is it you're
collecting within the game is it during
a match you're earning credit and that's
what allows you to buy the units during
the course of the game it's sort of at a
higher level as you go from match to
match your earning kudos at the end of
the game and those kudos or the in-game
currency that you're using to buy units
and other items that you can use three
matches so there's parts that you can
buy for your specific types of air Mac
there's different pilots that matching
them up with the different airmech types
will adjust their attributes and stats
in different ways so you know once
players started getting in there getting
their their claws into the game you'll
really have a lot to play around with it
and try different setups to see what
works best for them excellent and then
in terms of the i'm going to call them
creep i've probably got your own your
little soldiers that kind of come out
regularly those are the creeps can set
up lanes for those are they different
lanes for each map so each map has
different layouts there are you know
lanes that they will start coming down
and pass some sun lay out some apps have
like one specific kind of like a snake
path yeah so they'll be following the
path but there's other ones they have
just are wide open with all kinds of
different directions so really almost it
comes down to you to give those units
the orders to go in specific directions
or attack specific outposts as you're
working way and it adds to the strategy
sometimes sometimes you just want to
rush and and jump over all the outposts
along the way to get near to their base
the enemy base and and kind of lock down
one of the further outposts instead of
working your way no it's up to you and
your placed out a
what works best and you were saying
before we came on air that the original
Aramaic had a sort of a beta period at
some stage on the pc have you guys had
any such thing are you going two for the
360 version and have you managed to get
any sort of feedback from from people
who play the game because that's
oftentimes that's quite important my
really it's been it's been great to get
feedback from the pc community and and
hear what their their input is as as the
development team is working on both the
pc game hand the 360 version of the game
and so we're taking that into account
and then when we launch will this summer
you might have more announcements of how
we're going to handle the launch and
potential opportunities for advanced has
access it's interesting i'd say be
prepared to say but maybe 12 18 months
ago have the free-to-play boogeyman as
some folks in it really didn't want it
on consoles i think there was this sort
of territorial thing where they were
like that's some pc nonsense and
although some of them have worked out
some of them haven't and what seems to
be happening now when we see with stuff
like World of Tanks and with Ubisoft
entering the space with with games such
as as days it's almost as if the 360 has
become a forgotten console in terms of
Microsoft in many ways we come to e3
there's a massive Xbox booth there and
there's hardly any 360 game I know you
guys are in there but yeah like there's
not much there do you think that
free-to-play is actually going to be
really important for the longevity of
that console considering there are going
to be people who either can't upgrade or
don't want to upgrade and owned this
xbox 360 and all these games but they're
still looking for new games to play all
the time definitely I definitely think
there's there's a huge fan base on the
360 looking for new experiences new
games like this this is a type of game
that I don't think there's anything else
like it right now available on a console
whether it be free to play or otherwise
so I think that's where we're gonna
really shine with our mech arena and in
general I think we're
like I said that free-to-play had a
certain kind of growth period where
people were recognizing it as a certain
type of gameplay on certain platforms
but i think it's bears some developers
soul to the earth as well the man you
know that some some genuinely were
taking the pace and taking people's
money autonomy definitely I mean there
was there was definitely some of that
and and it's been a learning experience
for everybody freaking out what works
and what doesn't with free to play but
at this point I think we're getting to a
certain maturity with that type of
business model where players are
recognizing there there's value in the
games that are using that business model
beyond just you know trying to get that
that class but yeah I'm what what I
think is interesting about those
conversations now we see it on gamespot
on the shot in the forums and stuff is
that for a long time there the
conversations about what the game was
never even came up it was it's a
free-to-play game we're not gonna talk
about it where's now it seems and
obviously with with all these different
free-to-play games coming out you can't
just you can't just rest on the fact
that this is free and have make it be a
bum experience just so many of these
games coming in there as well that you
really have to you know same as pay for
games make sure that you're you're
making a point to do something new for
sure I think you know that the focus has
to be on the fund and the game the
player experience with the game
mechanics and and and players are savvy
bit players have so many options
nowadays will there be free to play or
you're spending you know their dollars
on the games where the buying they're
going to look for something that they're
going to have a fun experience and
that's what we're looking to provide
with our mech arenas is something where
you know people get online I just have
fun with the different options that
we're providing and even with
customization options there's some some
wacky stuff that the dev team carbon
games they have great sense of humor
there's a hats there you can get you
know sombrero oh I don't get umbrella
for your eyes fear your bad knee if
there's hats there's that some believe
us I'm buddy thank you so much for
coming on thank you this time some stage
one case Wacha I'm really appreciated at
one last time for the folks at on when
is airmech arena air when can people
I've ever it Emmerich arenas coming out
this summer on xbox 360 will be free to
play we'll have a lot more announcements
on air met kareena com so keep a lookout
and and we look forward to getting
that the players online awesome okay I
let you go off to the microsoft booth in
just a second and one let the folks at
home know there's a couple of more demos
coming up here codename steam announced
new 3ds game enhanced by Nintendo
yesterday is gonna be on the stage not
scoff as well but right up here in the
samsung sage next is a game I can't wait
to hear more about middle earth shadow
of mordor stick around